alors le rôle des des des des caïdes du
trafic de stup il peut à la fois être un
rôle de pompier à la fois un rôle de de
peroman en fonction des des des des
situations ils ont là par exemple suite
aux émeutes on peut penser
que beaucoup d'entre eux estiment que la
répression policière notamment le fait
d'aller au contact euh et d'interpeller
en allant jusqu'au bout c'està-dire en
utilisant la force euh bon ben des
policiers des gendarmes réfléchiront à
deux fois euh dans les mois les semaines
les mois ou les années qui viennent euh
avant de pousser euh jusqu'au bout une
interpellation s'ils semblent que ça se
complique s'ils sont encerclés si euh il
y a des jeunes de 14 15 ans qui se
rassemblent autour et cetera euh pour
avoir parler avec des policiers et des
gendarmes c'est clair qu'ils prennent en
compte euh et qu'ils ont aussi des
directifes des préfets en leur disant
voilà en ce moment il vaut mieux pas euh
trop aller au contact dans tel quartier
dans tel qu quartier euh et cetera donc
ça c'est euh malheureusement un un un un
risque et donc ils peuvent jouer des
émeutes de manière assez stratégique euh
vous vous avez dans dans dans dans dans
ces réseaux de trafic des gens qui sont
qui sont stupides qui sont un peu des
des têtees brûlées mais vous avez aussi
des gens qui sont qui sont très
intelligents et qui sont capables de de
de stratégie euh et et et d'avoir cette
cette réflexion et de jouer avec le
contrôle de la violence c'est-à-dire
soit le soit de la limiter soit au
contraire de dire voyez quand on quand
on veut on peut ouvrir et lâcher cette
cette violence et puis il y a aussi
parfois une impuissance parce que des
fois on me dit ah oui mais alors il y a
il y a des quartiers où il y a du gros
trafic de stup et pourtant il y a eu une
émeute et j'ai vu dans mes enquêtes
ethnographiques à plusieurs occasions
effectivement des des des caillites du
trafic de stup qui étaient dépassé par
la fougue juvénile en disant je ne sais
plus quoi faire donc il demandait en
fait au au numéro 1 qu'est-ce qu'on fait
quoi je les attrape je les frappe euh je
les menace et pourtant il me Ray ma
voiture ils reviennent à la charge donc
je me souviens d'une discussion où un
caite disait bon voilà qu'est-ce qu'il
faut faire est-ce qu'il faut que j'aille
jusqu'au meurtre euh pour pour les je
sais plus quoi faire donc c'était assez
drôle enfin j'ai si je pu utiliser
l'expression c'était de de de voir un
des caites du quartier qui qui tmignit
de son impuissance face à la à la
fougue des des adolescents donc il sont
pas tout puissants non plus et sur avec
beaucoup d'émotion sur un phénomène très
émotionnel avec des vidéos et cetera ils
peuvent être complètement dépassés et
débordés euh par euh par par cette
fougue adolescente